how in the past hour the US Federal
Reserve has increased interest rates for
only the third time since 2006 but the
second time in three months
the central bank raised the Fed Funds
rate what banks charge each other for
short-term loans to a range of 0.75
percent to one percent that represents a
quarter point increase from the last
upwards move in December is the chief
economist at Aberdeen Asset Management
she joins us now live from Edinburgh
Lucie I guess this would be more of a
surprise if the Fed hadn't moved yes it
certainly would have been an enormous
surprise I think everybody had expected
this to happen today the question really
was what the Fed then be signaling about
future rate raises this year and into
2018 yeah I mean what did you make of
the accompanying commentary I mean it
looks like we're gonna get at least two
more interest rate rises this year and
probably gradual increases over the next
few as well yes the guidance were being
given is two more rate races this year
and then another three in 2018 and
that's very clear we also talked about
the prospects for inflation and said
that the outlook for inflation is pretty
stable they're not terribly worried
about that they are pretty bullish on
growth and on employment but overall it
was a fairly measured gradualist message
yeah no real surprises in fact the
dollar has actually slipped since this
decision came out do you think in the
back of their mind the the Federal
Reserve are worried about pumping up the
dollar too much with more hawkish rate
increases possibly but to me it's very
hard to predict how currencies will
react to statements from central banks
so I think that they were themselves
really more focused on what they viewed
as the outlook for inflation and the
risks around their forecasts and they
seem to have gone today for a very
measured process they don't seem to be
terribly worried about the inflationary
risks in the US economy so I think it
was a very measured and a reassuring
message and as you say the dollar fell
and the equity market the stock market
in the United States seemed to like it
it rules quite sharply on the news okay
so loose I mean really inflation is
still relatively benign in the United
States at the moment be fight that
despite them having a jobless rate of
just 4.7
percent has the rate at which
unemployment can fall to without
generating higher inflation come down I
mean this is a big debating point on
both sides of the Atlantic isn't it yes
you're absolutely right both in the
United States and in the United Kingdom
central banks are looking at the current
jobless rates and seeing that actually
wage growth remains very subdued even
though the unemployment rate has fallen
both in America and over hearing in the
UK to very low levels
they're pretty puzzled about that they
don't really know what the answer is but
it does seem as if that sort of jobless
lorry the rate at which we drove kicks
in is quite a bit lower than we had
thought only a few years ago you
mentioned the equity markets just now
Lucy this is fantastic news of the
banking sector I mean this will really
pump up fur banking profits won't it in
the States well I think we don't want to
over egg it it's it's probably a good
thing for the banking sector that REITs
are on a gradually increasing path and
that they are set to rise further
because that's or benefits banks but
there's still a pretty low levels I
think there's just a general relief that
the world's biggest economy the United
States is starting to normalize interest
rates it's a sign that one country at
least is it's feeling a bit more normal
after this very long legacy period from
the global financial crisis as you say
the Fed has has obviously taken the view
that the US economy has turned a corner
here in the UK and in the eurozone of
course interest rates still at ultra low
levels which of the world's major
central banks do you think will be next
to start tightening monetary policy well
actually there is one other major
central bank that is currently more in
tightening more than that see the
central bank in China but if we put that
to one side as well and we start to look
at the UK and the eurozone it seems as
if interest rates both here and for the
European Central Bank are going to stay
ultra low levels for at least another
year there isn't any sign really yet
that they're starting to turn their
attention seriously to increasing
interest rates so I think for now as far
as the developed economies can
Seren it's still going to be a us-led
story briefly Lucy the Fed statement
refer to a business investment picking
up in the United States we could do with
a bit of that here couldn't we well
business investment is always a good
thing and yes at the moment what we seem
to have seen in the United Kingdom is
that there has been a bit of a pause on
business investment it hasn't been
picking up perhaps this is brexit
related companies are waiting to find
out more about what life is like post
the triggering of article 50 before they
site decide to undertake any expensive
investment plans so the postal still
seems to be in place here whereas in the
United States there's more confidence
that business investment is finally
taking off